And John said,
"George, you can't make a speech. You're four."
(Laughter)
"Only Grandpa and Uncle David and I are going to make speeches tonight."
But George insisted and insisted,
and finally, John took him up to the microphone,
and George said very loudly,
"Ladies and gentlemen!
May I have your attention, please?"
And everyone turned around, startled.
And George said,
"I'm glad it's daddy's birthday.
I'm glad we all get cake.
And Daddy, if you were little,
I'd be your friend."
(Gasp)
And I thought -- (Applause)
Thank you.
I thought that I was indebted even to Bobby Finkel,
because all those earlier experiences
were what had propelled me to this moment,
and I was finally unconditionally grateful
for a life I'd once have done anything to change.
The gay activist Harvey Milk was once asked by a younger gay man
what he could do to help the movement,
and Harvey Milk said,
"Go out and tell someone."
There's always somebody who wants to confiscate our humanity.
And there are always stories that restore it.
If we live out loud,
we can trounce the hatred,
and expand everyone's lives.
Forge meaning.
Build identity.
And then invite the world to share your joy.
Thank you.
(Applause)